saudi arabia is the world's largest oil
exporter and one of the world's biggest
polluters
if cop 26 is going to be a success it
needs countries like saudi arabia on
board
and if saudi arabia wants to protect its
future it needs to change its ways
the saudi economy and saudis themselves
have grown rich off the back of oil
riyadh these days is a city of fast cars
glass towers
and luxury shops
it is still strictly islamic in many
ways but it is increasingly liberal too
oil has bought saudi arabia
regional power
and global influence
and so if the country moves away from
oil which well ultimately they must
then saudi arabia's position as a major
player in the middle east
could be at risk
at a conference in riyadh senior
government ministers have been
discussing the future
[Music]
it has the backing of the crown prince
mohammed bin salman
it is the usual showcase of technical
revolutions supported by grand promises
that will land well in western capitals
saudi arabia's energy minister half
brother of the crown prince and one of
the country's most senior politicians
insists they can deliver
your power
and your influence globally and
regionally
has come
about as a result of the vast
wells of oil that you have if you move
away from that
potentially you might see that others
will compete for influence around the
world no we're not moving away from that
as opposed to
diversifying
with that
so we will be
you know i call ourselves now that we'll
be transforming ourselves to an energy
country
why
because we have reasons to believe that
we are there
we believe that we will continue to be
competitive
we believe that we could produce
hydrogen and again we will be the
cheapest producer of hydrogen saudi
arabia is having its hand forced no
doubt the world is moving away from oil
whether they like it or not
are we in a position now is the world in
position where
at some point in the future you can see
the end of oil
oil and gas will continue to be part of
the energy mix for decades that doesn't
mean
they will not be there will be the same
they will be cleaner
this is unusual in saudi arabia the
younger generation being asked and
giving their opinion
really we see hope you could see at the
end of the tunnel and as a youth as a
saudi youth i'm really proud that we're
going through that you see movements you
see youth being engaged
being empowered you do not change an
entire culture an entire
state built on energy in one day or
overnight everyone used to think that
our generation is all about oil and
money that's all that's definitely not
the case we definitely think more
greener we think more leadership we
think more innovation
saudi arabia's record on human rights
hangs over this country so too it's
involvement in the yemen conflict
but if they can get their climate
initiatives right
and to make good on their ambitious
promises the country's international
reputation will be the better for it
saudi arabia